so guys we are changing out the social
experiments a little bit more making a
bit more meaningful inshallah behind me
is the London central mosque inshallah
I'm going to be going there brother and
sister inshallah I'm gonna go and I'm
gonna spot in the first rows the first
stuff and see if there is a youngster
yes let's see what age maybe anywhere
from the age of maybe six to about 13 14
or 15. if I see any of them in the front
row row praying we've got to give for
them
let's go and find out let's go find this
champion inshallah
[Music]
there was two young boys that came
across I'm just trying to get some
information about them I want to see if
their parents are here going to ask
permission for parents I think that
Mumsy had said Son uh said the fathers
to an Uber so I'm gonna find out and
we're gonna speak to the mom for his
permission we're going to give them the
gift okay I'm gonna give it to both of
them the gift in here inshallah we're
going to talk to them a bit
let's find out
the gospel
can you call them is your mom here
oh okay when is she coming down
[Music]
what time are they coming down
okay because I wanted to um I wanted to
speak to the Mom I wanted to give them a
gift because you're not depending the
front room
I'm just like I'm looking for like I
came in today
so I have a gift for them
is there any chance you can go into the
women's section of us if Mom can go and
tell your mom you shouldn't come say
uncle wants to speak to you can we go
ask your mom if she can come outside I
want to ask her something
go ask your mom to come outside
can you go wait wait wait should she'll
come with me is it there
okay
how old are you huh
what's your name
my name is Ali I saw your sons they were
playing in the front row I just wanted
to ask you permission I want to give
them a gift uh this person I want to ask
you permission
um I do videos
so it's a social experiment what we do
is we go to the famous mosque and we see
which youngsters are praying in the
first row so them to a plane I have a
gift for them okay so if it's okay I'm
gonna go outside I'm gonna sit there
next to me and I'm just going to go for
it just do you mind them being on camera
okay
yeah all right so as you guys know uh
what we're trying to do now is we're
going to different massage it and trying
to catch the Gemma and we're looking for
young kids who are who are basically
praying Salah so I came into the Masjid
the first thing I noticed was
and and Musa yeah so what was you guys
doing
what was you guys doing in the Masjid no
no before that before that was you guys
did
huh
okay do you know can you recite
something for us
okay no problem can you can you can you
recite uh story class
can you try it
is
[Music]
[Applause]
which one do you know
yeah yes okay okay go on you do it
[Music]
yeah
okay so what I'm gonna do about the
sisters inshallah is when we see Young
Generation like that who are praying on
the first rolls the prophet Muhammad
peace before him said if you knew the
reward of pain in the first rose if
people couldn't settle the issue they
would draw lots subhanallah and not only
that the prophet sallam said that every
step that you take where do you live
like not exactly but it's it's weird
yeah how long is it to walk here roughly
three hours so you probably come with
car but still okay so he said every step
that you take towards the Masjid and to
see young people subhanallah you're
seven
and you're six mashallah they were in
the front row plane so what I'm gonna do
is Mom do we have the permission we're
going to give them a phone but I'll let
you do I know they're too young for this
but whatever you guys want to do
inshallah so what I'm going to do is
inshallah I'm going to give it a choice
here Pick A or B
hey
OB okay so a
is this are you ready
are you ready don't open it you're a in
it
go and open it
[Music]
oh it's it's a prayer what's inside the
prayer
iPhone 11 for you yeah and for you I
don't want to live with your MTN bit I'm
gonna give this to you
it's 150 pounds yeah that's for you yeah
I think mommy's gonna take that okay are
you happy
okay inshallah
yes he got the phone inshallah come here
give me the money okay I want you to do
me a favor yeah okay the first thing I
want you guys to do is number one pray
in Salah yeah never ever let go of
yourself okay no matter what happens how
hard life gets always stick to a seller
okay that's number one number two you
see Mommy
you always be obedient to her what does
Allah say in the Quran don't even say to
your mom yes if you want success in this
life Salah is the haq of Allah after
that is your mom and dad yeah okay make
sure you guys are obedient to your mom
okay is he good to mommy should we tell
him he's getting naughty sometimes
sometimes
well no no no no no nothingness you have
to obey Mom okay whatever she says
whatever you do give Mommy feet massage
okay okay so that's it what I'm gonna
say is
uh get the money out inshallah
so brothers and sisters inshallah we are
looking around the Masjid if you know
anybody youngsters who are regular in
your massage we would love to come and
give them this reward inshallah just
hold this up you know a little thumbs up
can you do like this
a generation who race to be in the front
uh Rose Brown sisters because in today's
time young kids their age are doing all
kinds of stuff and these kids may Allah
bless them in shall preserve them and
Mommy you're so lucky may Allah grant
them Jannah may Allah
thanks for allowing us to do this if
there's anything you would like to say
bless you inshallah take care enjoy the
phone okay maybe you can give it to my
mommy as a gift yeah yeah you think this
mommy is a gift
all right yeah inshallah thank you thank
you yes and next time we're going to get
you something as well take care look
after yourself
the prophet Muhammad peace be upon Him
used to give away camels and gifts to
the Bedouins to soften the hearts
towards Islam brothers and sisters when
we come to the massages in these places
the same thing we want to do is soften
the people's hearts more towards Islam
these youngsters who are coming to the
first rose to pray Salah Salah is the
first thing that you're going to be
asked under their judgment brothers and
sisters it is the second pillar of Islam
after Allah so it is our job and our
duties subhanallah to give them with
this brother and sisters this this
doesn't come in my pocket I wish I could
afford these things to give them I don't
I was sponsors and people who contribute
towards this do if you want to
contribute towards this if you're a
businessman you have somewhere for a
business woman and you want to give
towards it please get in contact with
myself inshallah and we can try to
arrange that and it will all go towards
giving these gifts to these youngsters
subhanallah and that's exactly what we
want to do brothers and sisters to our
organization salaam we have a project
called Salah plus where we teach a new
Muslim and born Muslims subhanallah how
to praise Salah step by step you can be
a part of that by enabling and teaching
someone new how to praise Salah brother
and sisters please go to the link in the
description box and donate whatever you
can so it can allow us brothers and
sisters to do more social experience
for you foreign